for trivial health problems like pee
common cold and so on
it's not advisable to have medicines
unnecessarily but many a type doctors
encounter patients requesting medicines
for such trivial problems so once a
smart doctor just gave some sugar pills
as medicine to them and surprisingly the
patient's reported feeling better
after consuming the pills so what
miraculous power did these sugar pills
have let's find out
[Music]
this effect was because of a
psychological phenomenon called the
placebo effect what does it mean here
the patients were given sugar pills but
they thought that they were actually
receiving real medicines so they had a
positive mindset that since they had
taken medicine they would feel better
and this led to a positive effect on
their health this is the placebo effect
now let's see another interesting
example some runners in a race were told
that they were given super oxygenated
water while it was just plain water but
surprisingly these runners ran much
faster than usual this led to the
runners positive mindset and they outdid
themselves pretty intriguing right in
the first example that we saw sugar
pills did the trick while in the second
it was the water they are called
placebos so can you think of the
applications of a placebo effect give it
a shot
placebo effect plays an important role
in the medicinal field it's used to test
the effectiveness of a new drug
let's say there's an organization which
has come up with a new painkiller and
wants to check its effectiveness some of
the volunteers in a research trial are
given a placebo while the others the
actual medicines
now if the volunteers taking the actual
drug demonstrated a significant
improvement over those taking the
placebo then it means the drug is
effective and we can use it as medicine
in this way it can be figured out if the
new drug actually has any effect or if
it's just another placebo we saw that a
placebo can be any substance that does
not have any direct effect but it's used
to change someone's mind set now let's
see one interesting example where we
don't even have to use a physical
substance as a placebo
normally a 30-minute exercise every day
is enough for a human to lead a healthy
life this is easy for people whose work
involves physical activities like
housekeeping but according to the study
it has been seen that many housekeepers
do not perceive their job as an exercise
so one interesting experiment was
conducted with female housekeepers the
women were grouped into Group one was
given a presentation where it was told
that the activities they indulgent at
work are actually good exercises and the
other group wasn't given this piece of
information after a few weeks to see the
result of the presentation these women
were tested on a few parameters
surprisingly the women from Group one
should quite a drop in body fat blood
pressure and were healthier but the ones
from group two didn't show any
significant changes so what do you think
happened here this example takes us to a
conclusion that placebo need not be any
physical substance it can be anything
that our mind believes in
even if it's just a thought now here
just the thought that they were
receiving a good amount of exercise
while they worked change their mindsets
to us their job and this resulted in a
positive change in their health
interesting isn't it we now know that
having the right mindset matters mindset
effects our performances and abilities
now we all have a common notion that
some of our abilities are innate for
example many of us think that people are
either born intelligent or they are not
we believe that the great scientists
were born intelligent so is intelligence
and innate ability instead of having
this fixed mindset can we improve our
intelligence by changing our mindset
this is your cue box to explore share
your findings in the comment section and
if this video has succeeded in changing
your mindset then do not forget to share
this video and do subscribe to our
Channel